all right our first store we got this
from The Daily Caller NBC deletes tweet
comparing immigrants to trash I just you
know I didn't expect it to go this far
so quickly so fast Ronda Santa sent 50
illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
and it was like a political nuclear bomb
take a look at this
NBC tweeted Florida Governor DeSantis
sending Asylum Seekers to Martha's
Vineyard is like a quote me taking my
trash out and just driving to different
areas where I live and just throwing my
trash there a founding member of a
foundation which helps refugees says wow
that is a not only indicative of NBC
News is what they're willing to publish
because they didn't need to choose that
quote but also these ngos these these
non-profits that claim to help these
people you see what they really think
about them it reminds me of when uh that
Osborne woman was on The View or
whatever Kelly Osborne
Deport these people who's going to clean
your toilet and they were like you
remember that yeah that's what she said
right specifically she asked Donald
Trump uh going against Donald Trump's
immigration policy quote who will clean
your toilet when you Deport he couldn't
he's even like the white woman that I
hired to clean my toilet next question
yeah you know many nothing not not
people don't know is many refugees from
multiple countries most countries that
you come in here is an asylum Seeker
you're required to take for a week in
anti-helmenthic medication that starts
with an eye you're required by the CDC
to take that medication for a week and
that's because you're talking about
ivermectins because it's a worms a worm
because it's so worms it's so common in
many of these Sound Stickers that
they're acquired by the CDC to take it
for a week really so Asylum Seekers
coming in your parasites have are given
Ivermectin yes wow mandatory for a week
wow you're looking up the CDC website
just to look at look at a look at
refugees the CDC cbcdc Refugee uh uh you
know therapeutic recruitment yeah
Ivermectin is an incredible medication
that has saved countless numbers of
lives used billions of times and it
comes from the soil in Japan and we
could get into the stopper we're going
to get into this topic a little bit but
uh we're just seeing there it is yeah
yeah look at that they're all Middle
Eastern Asia North African Latin
American and Caribbean refugees should
receive Ivermectin two doses 200 was it
micrograms per kilogram yeah orally once
a day for two days before departure to
the US that's really interesting I
didn't know that well um required CDC we
got a doctor here so there we go yeah
and um it's crazy what are we gonna do
now call it horse medicine and say the
CDC is forcing these things that bother
with that whole horse medicine thing is
every
pharmacological agent has a Veterinary
application why aren't we talking about
pepcids a Veterinary pepsin it's a
Veterinary pill you can get over the
counter at a pharmacy we we talked about
this weird um epinephrine yeah sheep
epinephrine is cheaper than the human
epinephrine granted the the human
epipens are like single dose instant
shots or whatever whereas like you can
buy a vial of the sheep stuff but but
don't do it do not do it do not take
Veterinary medication the point is
though why this one medicine yeah I I
really tried to figure out where it came
from I guess one couple tried it and
that there were multiple calls to poison
control centers asking questions about
it but all I can find is one game well
well the Rolling Stones did a very big
investigative piece about how people in
a hospital in Oklahoma were oding on it
so much that of course it filled up the
emergency rooms and the whole story was
absolutely made up out of nowhere the
Rolling Stone should be absolutely
disgraced with themselves and and just
run out of town run out of business with
the way that they lanyard this this
medication that has saved so many lives
I mean river blindness I've never been a
fan uh since the since the get-go with
um kovid that people have been pushing
these Therapeutics and I felt like it
was very tribal me too well but I do
want to say I am very impressed in how
we immediately shifted from a
immigration story right into Ivermectin
and also you know what do you know about
Chinese liver flukes in the eye why why
do you know about that that river
blindness yeah because when when uh the
whole I imagine things oh they discussed
it okay well it's all in the news and
it's it's a rare illness is it like in
the river they would swim into the
eyeball when they're swimming underwater
guys it was a called a Chinese liver
fluke we used to look for it in the eye
I don't know how it gets there but it
but I think in Africa it's really really
common and so uh Ivermectin is like a un
certified like oh yeah but I want to I
want to stress this too I really do
think that when it came to covet I I did
not when I got kovid this is the
craziest thing I didn't want it I said I
didn't want it yeah they gave me
monoclonal antibodies that that works me
up right right and then four days later
they were like well were your doctor we
prescribed it and I was like but I'm I
feel fine now and so even when I went on
Rogan I said I I'm not you know
confident in this because I know there's
a lot of studies but there's a lot of
contradiction let me just tell you let
me just say just real quick my point was
The Daily Beast still ended up writing
that I was the poster boy for Ivermectin
despite me constantly being like nah
well let me add to that being not uh the
you know back when we had nothing to
offer it's like all right whatever I saw
it used a ton and it was like people
that were getting sick just kept getting
sick they got worse some people that
were gonna get well got well and I don't
know the medicine made any difference as
opposed to now with paxilvid and
monoclone antibodies they're better the
next day I mean it's just a pow they get
better immediately oh my goodness well
too well actually because they get these
rebounds that are kind of common and I'm
wondering if it's affecting the immune
response my daughter took paxilvid
better in two days and then was not
rebound but reinfected six weeks later
wow and so two months later and it was
like uh she should have still been
immune but that's the drug that was also
approved under emergency protocol is
that correct and I think some people are
also saying that their side effects is
this taste in their mouth of crap that
they can't get out from this side effect
and also there's a lot of people who
took it like Joe Biden and I think
another very prominent politician that
had a rebound so still everything's not
known and when it comes to the
antibodies we've got to remember in
January the Biden Administration uh got
rid of antibodies and told everyone not
to use it and prevented people from
using it when it could have saved lives
which is absolutely insane I want to ask
you um do you know the name of the of
the phenomenon when you taste crap in
your mouth and everything tastes like
crap you mean from paxilvid no it's not
just from Pax live there's a there's a
word syndrome yeah
I think it's because I remember I
remember people were getting coveted
yeah and then like there's a video of a
woman crying saying everything tastes
like sewage that's rare that's rare
usually it just doesn't taste or tastes
salty discussions the Distortion of the
sense of taste is that kind of like
disgusting
I guess did they ever figure out what
kovid was doing to people because I
heard that it was somehow causing the
red blood cells to not be able to
transport oxygen yes that's probably
true probably due to microvascular
injury this this something by the spike
protein and the lining over the
endothelium that's where the story is we
don't have it fully worked out yet but
it was causing our tiniest vessels to
dysfunction so nutrients and oxygen and
immune cells so it's a lot of the brain
stuff we've been worrying about is
because of that microvascular in fact
it's pretty well established that the
old factory stuff the smell stuff is
from this microvascular oh let's let the
brain fog just really just one more
click there was another study there was
another another rooting this per year
program I just want to say one more
thing because because this is such an
important thing I can't stop I'm
building the roads as well just really
good there's a new study released in the
New England Journal of Medicine a study
from Israel that talked about how
paxilovid had no benefits to people
under 65. that's the earliest that is
that has been that is so so generally
with covid today we know know what we're
doing with vaccines over the age of 75
and Pax live it over 65. otherwise we
don't really fully know what we're doing
what is back by the sense intense of the
from us from a clinical and scientific
standpoint we have we're very clear
we're very very solid you know over 75
over 65 under that we're gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw a lasso around this and
yank it right back
for me
pull it back to uh uh what's going on
with the the immigrations yes wait a
minute but we'll get back into this too
I don't wanna like I don't want to just
shut that down but we actually just have
a handful of other stories related to
the immigration crisis it's the new
Pfizer drug let me let me see if I can
uh I want to pull up this tweet and kind
of wrap up the segment so good this is
John Hayward to tweet it's one sending
50 migrants to Martha's Vineyard is like
the Holocaust too hahaha you just gave
us a chance to show how compassionate we
are three we demand emergency service
assistance four get these damn migrants
off Island 5 called the National Guard
all in 24 hours this is the red pilling
of of what you know migrancy can become
overly compassionate to a destructive
purpose like yeah the idea of letting
people that are suffering in and helping
them is great but when you actually see
what that means for an infrastructure
that can't handle it it's it can become
destroyed no no no you're wrong the
infrastructure can handle it go on
Airbnb right now and you look at
Martha's Vineyard there's enough houses
that are available there's enough rooms
that are available the Obamas have
enough mansions that are available and
someone said today on Twitter that and
it caught my attention uh I'm sorry
Mansions being one yeah yeah of course
yeah of course but someone said
something on Twitter that really caught
my attention today and it said that the
Democrats have a new immigration policy
and it's quote you don't got to go home
but you can't stay here and that's
exactly what happened in Martha's
Vineyard and it's and it's and and
DeSantis put it right on their doorsteps
and they showed what kind of big
Hypocrites they are it's it's hilarious
unfortunately it's a violation of basic
moral certainly content moral principles
of using people as a means to an end but
it's a problem on all sides yeah I agree
but the issue is that Biden has been
doing it the Biden Administration
trafficking the children yeah and so but
but here's the way I see it
for DeSantis we know there's a political
stunt in Martha's Vineyard specifically
I'm not a fan of any of these people
doing it now New York City is sending
them back to Florida it's just outright
crazy but here's the funny thing as they
rag on Abbott and DeSantis over this
Biden's been sending the migrants to New
York City so they completely ignore the
problem when it's Biden doing it sending
them to New York then as soon as Abbott
or DeSantis does it all of a sudden now
it's a humanitarian crisis is that them
or is that the media
yeah what's the difference yeah but this
blaming like Biden or DeSantis like
isn't it the cartels that are running
human trafficking across our border it
is leftist ngos with U.S influence going
down and telling them the borders open
and jobs are waiting for that that's
right you had mentioned before the show
that it might be big money involved I
don't know if so there's videos we've
seen this during the big Caravans of
people who look American talking and
working with these people and they're
being told that you can come up no one
will stop you and there's jobs waiting
you were saying Ami Horowitz yeah I mean
Horowitz has some good videos on this he
embedded himself he was he said there's
rail cars of food and pods a hospital
and a school that all travels with them
I mean it's thousands of people going
thousands of miles what do you think you
just rely on the the kindness of
strangers as you walk into their Town
foreign's profiting off of it they're
like getting paid it's human trafficking
essentially What's Happening Here
I wouldn't be surprised if there's big
business in the US behind it for cheap
labor things like that we've seen it in
the past well Bernie Sanders called it a
Koch brothers plan a Billionaire's plan
to get a bunch of cheap labor to of
course lower wages and increase the
housing costs for everyone else thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there